alright let's talk about atheism a
little bit we've covered it a bunch on
the show and I thought this was really
interesting a study called the free
thought report 2013 found out that there
are 13 countries around the world where
you can face execution under the law for
being an atheist we've got a list of the
countries Afghanistan Iran Malaysia
Maldives Mauritania Nigeria Pakistan
Qatar Saudi Arabia Somalia Sudan United
Arab Emirates Yemen okay and
unfortunately none of those countries
surprise anyone I think that knows
anything about that part of the world we
did a story last week on the seven
countries in the world that you can
still be put to death for being gay a
bunch of them were on there so before we
get into the the specifics about atheism
should anything that goes on in that
part of the world surprised us how do we
drag them out of the Dark Ages and into
some sort of enlightenment that maybe
we're inherited we had enlightenment
anywhere we're past enlightenment now
we're in the we're on the other side of
enlightenment now but can we just get
them a little bit to come this way the
regime's of some of these countries are
not what we would call democratic even
though they might say over the
Democratic Republic so it's a lot of
control I think that's that's part of it
and religion is a great way to
institutionalize control so that's what
I think is at work here at base yeah I'm
not surprised I'm also disappointed
though okay so the big thing on TV this
week was cosmos came back on Sunday
night the Carl Sagan classic and there
was an interesting piece where they they
did some animation they gave us some
cartoons and Giordano give me his last
name Bruno where he was basically
condemned to a life in jail because he
kept telling everyone that the universe
is infinitely bigger than we think it is
which is now something we know is
basically a scientific fact that you
know and they did this really
interesting thing with the arrow and if
the arrow goes through the universe and
it ends somewhere well then what's on
the other side of the end and that was
sort of how they visualized it for us
these countries haven't got out and they
show basically how the church basically
destroyed this guy's life even though he
was
like Oh our God made this huge universe
our God did this for us he was still
acting in the confines of religion yeah
it just wasn't the right way right so I
think there's a great parallel to what
was going on then and this is you know
many hundred years ago versus what's
happening in these countries now why is
it that religious why can't they make
some sort of reconciliation between
belief and science well I mean and it's
not even necessarily belief in science
it's their belief against all other
beliefs I mean they I mean allegedly
would execute Baha'i or Christians as
well you know which I think that the I
think kind of HuffPo with the article at
least that I read about this sort of
misses that a little bit because you
know maybe it's HuffPo and that's more
interesting obviously it's about
education I guess and it's about saying
you know the people who are are there if
they have the power to sort of
understand freedom from a religious
standpoint they're gonna do what they
what they have to do to get that but
unfortunately you know that's not ever
an easy safe inexpensive or fast process
yeah so every week that we do some sort
of international story whether it's
about Syria or Ukraine or something
because I'm an American I bring it back
to what can America's role be in this
every time we do something
internationally everyone hates us and if
we don't do anything people hate us too
so if we're gonna be hated either way is
there anything we can do to either to
protect the safety of these people or to
push the regimes to do more to help them
or it's just is it sort of a lost cause
at this point atheism is not mainstream
in America - I mean we kind of associate
being patriotic with being religious
yeah I don't think that's a fair
equivocation but that's sort of the
mindset atheists don't do that well in
terms of discrimination in the United
States either and it yes and we were
speaking about this earlier religion or
imposed religion is a means of keeping
people from thinking on their own and
getting their their ideas past what the
state's ideas are so yes there is a some
sort of a relation there I don't know
that we're going to do anything as a
nation to help atheists internationally
at this point yeah okay so I'm gonna
stick with America because I think you
make a good point it seems to me that we
haven't
huge percentage of people that are sort
of closeted atheists I mean by some
studies they say it's something like 20%
of the United States now identifies with
atheism that that would be a huge
political movement why don't we see more
do they just not want to get mixed up in
politics because of the sort of
left/right nature you'll get shunned you
maybe can't gin up people's fears as
much I think it's definitely would be
one of the things you probably wouldn't
bring up at a cocktail party I guess
depending on where you are in the
country but it's not so mainstream that
it's like people if they are if they're
not atheists I think that they they
don't accept it in the same way that we
sort of allow exception for other sort
of minority viewpoints or minorities I
think that the the way that America
could help right is if we recognize a
theism as just another facet of
religious freedom right and so we say
well our moral relativity allows us to
see that as as a problem because we
think here like everybody should be
allowed to do what they want to do and
so if we're a lot you know able to
communicate communicate that it doesn't
have to be about atheism everybody is
helped you know and I think that at the
end of the day that's you know that's
that's better yeah I think that's
actually a really good point if you
frame it in a context that they can sort
of understand then it might actually
make some sense do we need more
celebrities to be I say that only
half-jokingly but if we had a couple
people you know Barney Frank
the congressman many you know for 30
years out of Massachusetts he was openly
gay in the early 80s he didn't come out
as an atheist until about six months or
a year ago on Real Time with Bill Maher
so he was more comfortable saying I'm
gay which if you said that in the 80s
that certainly wasn't helping his
political career it's not really helping
anyone's political career now but he had
to wait till he retired to say he was an
atheist so does that just sort of say it
all as to where we're at in terms of
definitely need to be strides made there
needs to be someone who's ready to
martyr himself or herself I guess people
are going to not accept it at first I
mean dealing even with members of my own
family
they're horrified
the idea of atheism and but they don't
really seem to understand what it means
either I think once we get more of that
information out there and more
understanding I what do you think the
misconception is that somehow you don't
believe anything like you're alive I
don't care about children and America
it's it's just very weird and oddly out
blown yeah do you think cosmos is gonna
actually help in this regard so it's not
talking about atheism specifically at
least not in the one episode that's been
out but sort of just bringing science to
a understandable level giving us a
little bit of that I know that the
Catholic League was very upset with
cosmos they thought they were being
attacked basically just for giving
factual for religion and science to
co-exist together I think throughout
history it's obviously kind of always
been this like play back and forth
between them and I think now that the
rapid advancements in information and
technology allow us to sort of have more
explainable answers to things that we
turn to religion to explain as that
occurs I think more people will sort of
be you know especially of our generation
are less entranced by the idea of
religion but it depends on who you ask
I mean you're you sort of ask the
question you know what can we do to help
you know the cause of the atheist it's
like if you're not an atheist then like
there is nothing you can do and I mean I
think that talking about atheists as
like an oppressed people is maybe a
little bit absurd you know because I
think the whole idea is that your hands
off kind of thing or it's like we should
be free to do whatever we want to do and
if we really believe in that if we as a
country as our founding then let's all
just do that and right and I think I
think a lot of people and I know in the
YouTube comments people are gonna be
saying well even in those countries
you're free to believe whatever you want
because the government can't get into
your brain but there's a difference
between you know privately believing
what you want and still being able to
express yourself as a human being I
think Neil deGrasse Tyson he's never
come out and said I'm an atheist he's I
think he's veered away from that and I
think you've done that for a good reason
so you think he probably is it all
understand they make for him I don't
know but it's possible right but but
he's never really said like I reject
legend entirely and it's all a sham he's
never said that yeah very interesting
Neil deGrasse Tyson if you want to come
on the show and discuss I'd be happy to
have yet